was ist das das playbook ist und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
hacker show wie immer stellt euch heute
die 345 und dabei hab ich den witz und
die erstanwendung des heutigen tages
stammt von opticum hd heißt mega hacker
ins chaos
ich steck lächerlich gratis test alter
junge
alles live ich drüber apple zurück
gepackt jetzt hängt in der luft
what the [ __ ] wie immer geht die bilder
nicht aus wenn ihr aufnehmen versucht
mehr als 3 erfasst zu haben so dass man
als einstieg ja hat er beim springen zur
nächsten sendung okay die einladung
stammt von krieg schreibt nicht vor was
er davon hält reinschreiben sonst noch
immer an
und warum haben alle diese schwarzen
ränder ich verstehe es nicht okay ich
dachte der gelbe fliegt jetzt los auf
einmal okay soweit alles legend aus ja
alles klar
okay der wort sich hoch oder
begleitender begleiten ja er gleitet
alles klar
es gehört einfach schön rüber geworden
dass du quasi auf der stelle einfach so
weiter ja genau leiden heißt das du
nicht hoch fliegt quasi sondern dass du
auf der stelle so oder so runter geht
deswegen hat er sich auch hoch gebaut
was auf genau da baut er sich hoch weil
er sonst gehe ich dahin kommt ja jetzt
zack zack zack zack zack kleider darüber
landet auf dem bett ist es dann leistet
aktuell habe ich jeden fall würde ich
sagen hat spd brach gebaut
eiskalt dem nichts gefallen aber das ist
eine gute taktik wenn man erkennt ihn
die leute beschäftigen
berger baut sich hoch da der kunst die
hacks angemacht und dann das bett und
runter und alle kinder so die einsendung
stammt von rage monkey heißt dezenter
fleischacker herz alter volle texture
pack oder quadrat hat er oben links und
alles drin selbst verarbeitet das ist
richtig zitiert die gegend läuft alles
klar
egal ob junge ist dazwischen response
als in seiner pace aber er hat halt nur
freude
man denkt sie nichts läuft auf einfach
der typ von links pfarrer sie sehr sehr
sehr sehr leise einsendung rage monkey
danke dafür würde sagen wir springen
dabei direkt zur nächsten
diese multi
dass der beyblade er macht einfach den
dance das gibt's doch nicht
ja aber er hat dann auch mit klarer
getanzt
das ist ein nicht so geil junge das
sieht einfach nicht mehr wie ein spieler
aus what the [ __ ] oskar huetter kopf
über das leben er macht das eiskalt die
ganze zeit was ist mit diesem jungen los
ohne wird etwas was die menschen im
leben erreichen wollen ist die ganze
natürlich einer den jesus ich frage mich
ob der gemeinde sitzt ja vor dem rechner
nicht weggegangen hatte ich eine pizza
gemacht sondern es steuert das wirklich
die ganze durch die gegend und hat die
ganze zeit diese sicht dass er sich so
krass dreht dass einem da nicht übel
wird man als pete aber dieses beyblade
hab ich ja noch nie gesehen würde wenn
ihr wisst wie der kreis kann es
natürlich die kommentare schreiben
also dieses krasse drehen das hat echt
ein beyblade dass der berg ich eine bake
jetzt ich bin gespannt
also recht klein arena ex jako hinter
sollten mittlerweile alle bemerkt haben
die hobbys
alles klar so schnell kompakt durchs
gesehen die holt er weg und der andere
braucht boxen oder schlagen oder ja kann
man kann man schon ja das beste ist dass
dem täter nicht schlecht wird floßbau
twitter brand
das klingt nicht schlecht wenn die ganze
zeit sich so eine kacke anschaut grad
fahrenheit gegenverkehr katja dafür
notwendigen beschreibung und wenn es
nicht immer dann ist es halt nicht
gewesen was ich abschließend sagen
möchte zur hacker sowieso hecken leute
was hat man davon aus am ende habe es in
die kommentare